you know Draya I've been really looking
forward to all the machine learning at
cloud nexus here that's a hot topic is a
hot topic so it's about time that we
checked it out
we're here with Kaz Kaz would you mind
introducing yourself and telling
everybody out there what you do thank
you so much I'm Kaz I'm a developer
advocate for Google cloud and here we
have the so called find you can G demo
solutions where you can tell you some
voice commands to the tablet so that the
robot can understand your voice command
and try to find the best candy for you
and pick it up by recognizing the image
so there's a number of different machine
learning algorithms going on they're
both in the voice recognition and
understanding not just what you said but
what it means as well as selecting the
candy can you just walk us through that
flow yeah so initially it's using the
voice speech API to recognize your voice
and then it uses the natural language
API to understand the words inside the
sentence and then it uses the class
machine learning to use the algorithm is
called water to Bay water to Becky's and
algorithm is used to understand the
meaning of ability words so it
understands the difficulty similarity
between the hot and spicy or creamy and
milky and then it tries to use the order
to choose the best attendees typical and
finally it uses the cloud ml again to
recognize the two the image recognition
on the each object it's a lot of
machinery yes fond of them all right
shall we try it yeah yeah you can try it
let's see I like mint
little voice recognition I see it it's
finding the whole sentence there
it knows what each of those words is I
bet she's going to pick out the noun
right yes so he understands all the
possible speeds reckon now active and
now if chooses the best can deploy look
it chooses mints so talks if I know
we're sorting some candy here but talk
to us like how this translate for
enterprises and for businesses so Jackie
actually this is a miniature version of
the real world use cases and here we we
have the all the displays for the
accouterments order M actually we have a
real capable farmer in Japan who
introduced who use these same
technologies to build his own Cuban
sorter and she spent only a fifteen
dollars to build his own equipment sort
of by using equal cross as in learning
technology that's really cool yeah so
essentially takes the best prototype of
that and kind of buckets them or yeah
yeah so he wanted to build the machine
hood that can sort out the old all the
cucumber's into nine different classes
and she took the nine thousand different
photos for the his cucumbers and now and
also building sort of by using the
brotherly pact and download the tensile
draw the machine learning library from
Google the beaches on sorter and the
point here is that either has to be an
cutting edge data scientist or machine
learning expert to getting started with
the latest machine learning technology